[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory The
Wizarding World has captivated our
imaginations for decades a realm filled
with magic wonder and extraordinary
beings but have you ever noticed that in
this vast magical world there is a
distinct absence of muggle technology
while the functionality of muggle Tech
May pale in comparison with the
capabilities of magic we do have to
remember that the Wizarding World is
host to all kinds of magical beings
muggle borns included and while the
Wizarding World May sometimes seem like
a separate realm altogether the
surprisingly High number of muggleborn
witches and wizards that find themselves
integrated into this Enchanted Society
do bring with them a distinctly unique
type of knowledge where Arthur Weasley a
pure blood wizard may find himself in
entirely preoccupied overanalyzing the
functionality of a rubber duck a young
muggleborn wizard may be versed in an
entire worlds worth of advanced Tech I
wonder with some knowledge of modern
technology from muggle World why don't
we see the use of more muggle technology
in The Wizarding World and if muggle
Tech did make an appearance in The
Wizarding World would it be a net
negative or net positive and is the
distinct lack of muggle Tech a
deliberate choice by the was in
community or are there inherent
limitations that prevent the
incorporation of such Tech today we're
going to be exploring these very topics
and attempting to decipher whether or
not Michel Tech has a place in Wizarding
Society let's dive in muggle relations
cultural barriers when making
comparisons between the Muggle and
magical worlds it's imperative that we
first recognize relevant cultural
barriers particularly as it's this
cultural VI that serves as a major
contributor to the absence of muggle
Tech in Widing Society by the 17th
century wizard muggle relations were in
Dire Straits the persecution of witches
and wizards had been on the rise
throughout Europe since the early 15th
century which caused many in The
Wizarding Community to feel a deep sense
of fear and danger in Great Britain the
newly formed Ministry of magic
desperately attempted to establish
communication with the Muggle British
Monarchy who at the time was under the
joint rule of William III and Mary II
the ministry's special delegation
pleaded for the protection of wizards
under muggle law seeking official
recognition for their magical Brethren
however the heartfelt appeals of the
British Ministry fell on deaf ears the
lack of response from the British
Monarchy seemed to be the final straw
that led wizard kind to choose a
different path a path surrounded in
secrecy hidden from Muggles and their
ever increasing
hostility left with no choice but the
adoption of secrecy wizard kind was
forced to withdraw from the world of
Muggles retreating into their own
magical realm this in turn led to the
enactment of the international statute
of Wizarding secrecy a protective
measure that has enabled Wizarding
Society to remain in relative peace for
centuries the law was put in place by
the international Confederation of
wizards a Wizarding intergovernmental
organization that's roughly equivalent
to the United Nations in the Muggle
world this law first signed in 1689 and
officially ratified in 1692 was created
to conceal the existence of witches and
wizards from the Muggle population it
was designed to safeguard the magical
world through the implementation of
strict secrecy measures preventing
Muggles from discovering the existence
of The Wizarding community and their
magical abilities the introduction of
the statute ushered in an era of secrecy
and separation between the wizard Ing
and Muckle worlds but while it offered
protection to witches and wizards it
also posed challenges and restrictions
on their interactions with Muggles and
after the statute was ushered in witches
and wizards formed their own world a
world with no Muggles and more
importantly a world that they owed to
their magical abilities and it's this
very separation that led to a newly
formed sense of identity and Community
within the Wizarding World that resists
the influence of muggle technology
moreover the instances of magical
persecution in the past likely create a
psychological barrier that prevents The
Wizarding Community from fully embracing
anything muggle technology included
overall cultural barriers and a sense of
preservation contribute to the absence
of Muckle technology in The Wizarding
World Wizards and witches value their
distinct magical Heritage and may see
the integration of muggle technology as
a dilution of their culture and
tradition the historical tensions and
the desire to maintain a separate
identity further reinforce this
reluctance to embrace muggle tech there
are however other important factors that
limit the incorporation of muggle
technology challenges while muggle
Technologies like computers smartphones
and Machinery have become integral parts
of our daily lives The Wizarding World
relies heavily on parchment quills and
owls for communication and it's this
unanimous choice to adhere to such
traditional methods that causes me to
ponder the advantages this modern
technology could offer the magical world
cultural identity aside what is it that
drives witches and wizard to avoid the
use of muggle Tech in all aspects and is
the absence of muggle technology a
hindrance or a deliberate choice that
ensures The Wizarding World remains
Untouched by the advancements of their
muggle counterparts here are a few of my
thoughts on the subject fundamental
incompatibilities one of the the most
significant aspects of this conversation
to consider is that there are
fundamental incompatibilities between
Magic and technology in case you weren't
already aware magic can adversely affect
Muckle technology rendering it useless
or causing it to malfunction electrical
devices and machines may stop working or
act erratically in the presence of
strong magical forces they just don't
work well together side by side and
while muggle technology relies on
predictable and logical systems we have
to remember that mag is unpredictable as
a result any integration attempts must
overcome this core incompatibility to
work
effectively there's no need another
aspect to consider is that the Wizarding
World offers unique magical Alternatives
which serve as more convenient solutions
to Everyday needs further diminishing
the Reliance on muggle inventions one
such example is the flu Network a
magical transportation system that
allows witches and wizes to travel
instantaneously between fireplaces
unlike Muckle transportation systems
that require infrastructure roads and
vehicles the flu Network eliminates the
need for physical travel altogether it
provides a fascinating alternative but
showcases The Wizarding world's ability
to achieve quick and convenient
Transportation without the use of
conventional muggle technology similarly
magical communication methods offer
alternatives to muggle Tech like phones
and email owls serve as reliable
Messengers for sending letters and
packages in The Wizarding World with the
use of magical enchantments the owls can
Traverse great distances in a remarkably
short time providing a reliable and
efficient means of communication the
existence of these Wizarding World
equivalents demonstrates the unique and
self-sufficient nature of the magical
Community with their own magical
Solutions available witches and wizards
have limited Reliance on Muckle
technology as they possess Alternatives
that are often more efficient and
tailored to their magical needs
education The Wizarding education system
has traditionally focused on magical
education with very little emphasis on
Muckle technology as a result Wizards
and witches May lack the necessary
knowledge skills and exposure to adopt
muggle technology additionally The
Wizarding World has long been isolated
from technological advancements in the
Muggle World keeping up with rapidly
advancing muggle technology may be a
challenge making it challenging for the
wi world to integrate it effectively
educational reforms and financial
investments may be necessary to overcome
these
limitations guns no topic surrounding
the use of muggle technology can be
complete without discussing guns in a
world full of powerful spells that bear
extreme destructive potential I've
always wondered what the mindset is
surrounding guns in The Wizarding World
we don't see guns much and I think the
most notable instance of a wizard
showing their attitude towards guns is
when Hagrid bends Vernon dley shotgun in
the philosopher stone Hagrid's not even
remotely afraid of the gun being pointed
at him but I don't think that it's
because he feels that he's invulnerable
to it it's because he knows that Vernon
is too much of a coward to actually
properly pull the trigger but that does
sort of make me wonder how destructive
could a weapon like a gun actually be in
the Wizarding World surely it wouldn't
overshadow magic otherwise witches and
wizards would be using guns just like
Muggles right I did some digging online
and there seems to be a general
consensus among many fans that at one
point in time Rowling actually spoke on
this matter revealing that the power of
a gun in many instances outweighs the
power of magic specifically in the
instance of a duel in a fight between a
muggle with a shotgun and a wizard with
a wand the Muggle will win however I'm
really not sure of the legitimacy of
this quote I'd really have to find the
exact source to go by this I'm also not
convinced I think that though a gun
could bear some destructive potential
magic is so much more
versatile I think that the primary
reason that guns aren't used by the
large majority of witches and wizards is
the fact that it's just as I mentioned
earlier not a part of their culture they
don't exist anywhere they're not
advertised no one owns them there's no
legislation surrounding them and
certainly no one is using them many
witches and wizards grow up in a world
entirely devoid of weapons like that and
to suppose that aspect of Muckle culture
just never found its way in we know of
course that in addition to the witches
and wizards that have spent their entire
lives in The Wizarding World there are
also witches and wizards that grew up in
the Muggle world and spent a
considerable amount of time there before
attending Hogwarts presumably these
witches and wizards are at least
somewhat familiar with muggle technology
like guns so if anyone were to consider
using a weapon like a gun then these
would be the people now my question is
why why don't these halfblood and Muckle
born witches and wizards spice up the
battle against the Death Eaters and pull
out some guns I think that one of the
reason that guns are never used is
because witches and wizards are taught
not to adopt that part of muggle society
and many other parts of muggle Society
for that matter the primary goal of the
ministry of magic and witing government
is upholding the statute of secrecy
which upholds The Divide between muggle
and magical worlds this is best
explained by Hagrid to Harry in the
philos Stone Ministry of magic messing
things up as usual Do's a Ministry of
magic of course they want a dumbledor
for minister of course but he'd never
leave Hogwarts so old Cornelius fudge
got the job bungler if there ever was
one so he Pelt Dumbledore with owls
every morning asking for advice but what
does a Ministry of magic do well their
main job is to keep it from the Muggles
that they're still witches and wizards
up and down the country why why blim me
Harry everyone would be wanting Magic
solutions to their problems nah we're
best left alone what this means is that
among all other things that the ministry
handles their ultimate responsibility is
to ensure that there is a harmonious and
distinctly segregated relationship with
the Muggle World secrecy is of utmost
importance however In this passage
Hagrid seems to suggest that the statute
of secrecy is upheld because Muggles
would want things from witches and
wizards they'd want magical solutions to
their problems and who knows what would
come with that in short magic is more
impressive than technology and I can't
see why on Earth wizards would want to
embrace the technology of the very
people that sought to oppress them
especially if it meant exposing the
magical world and that's it for this
video did I miss anything please let me
know down in the comment section below
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel also
be sure to check out extra content on my
second Channel Harry Potter the extra as
well as Audio Only content on Spotify
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to
live